one order of operations for starting a
startup more often than not when I
talked to a talented technical person
who's thinking about becoming a founder
their number one blockers that they
don't have an idea at some point during
their formative years they learned that
every great startup started with a great
idea and if the idea isn't amazing
usually as judged by peers parents or
other people with little startup
experience the startup will fail alright
I think I wrote this because this is the
number one excuse I hear from people who
want to start a startup and and it's so
interesting to me I think that like
there are all of these old
entrepreneurial rules and business best
practices that that I think that it
people just want to apply hand-in-glove
to new industry mmm and I think tech
startups might be a little different um
and so interestingly enough like I don't
even think people are really taught how
to find ideas so like I feel as though
people are sitting there saying I don't
have an idea and they don't even really
understand a process by which to get one
yeah they think they think that it's
supposed to like happen organically like
it's like almost like out of the
cartoons or like a light bulb goes off
the top of your head and like that's not
really how it works and so I what I
wanted to do with this essay was give
people a framework that they could try
to use to come up with an idea so
instead of this being a passive process
can be active process I think one of the
things that like might be hard for
people to see is like now being in this
world for so long I have a lot of
friends who wanted to do a startup and
didn't know what they wanted to do and
then came up with an idea and we're very
successful and so like I've seen this
happen with a lot of people and so
that's kind of where I've come up with
this thought mm-hmm so you break it out
into three one two three or several
steps so this is I'm gonna outline and
then we can explain so the order of
operations here's where I'd start is
there any particular problem that you're
passionate about the next step once you
decide on a problem find some print
friends and brainstorm potential
solutions to the problem
the next step at this point the most
important thing is to make that spark
turn into a fire is to work together and
build and launch an MVP yes
and that's basically it yeah yeah it's
not that complex yeah it's hard but it's
not that complex no it's not so so let's
start at the beginning
a particular passion a problem in
passion right so I think oftentimes I'll
give you the conversation that I had
with with a founder I was at a
conference over the weekend called afro
tech and they're a bunch of young people
who wanted to start companies there and
this woman walked up to me and she said
I have an idea I'm doing a startup that
helps other startups and I call this
like a meta startup and this is startups
that I kind of don't like because it's
like in some ways I think it's like a
cop-out it's like hey I'm given I want
to help give other startups advice and
guidance but I haven't really done a
sort of myself like it's yeah I don't
know it's just it's it's it's not great
and so I dug in I was like okay so
what's a problem that you have and it
was interesting so the woman was a
mother and she said well the problems I
have is that I there are a lot of places
when I go somewhere new there are a lot
of places where I don't know if I can
use my stroller with my baby because
it's like hard to get around or if I'm
walking on the street does it have you
know the proper sidewalks and so and so
forth so I'd love like some type of
product that would like tell me what
path I should take that's like stroller
friendly and I said ok that's we're
getting somewhere right now we're not
we're not in like this I met an idea and
now we're actually solving a problem
directly great but I I asked her hey can
you judge this by two things first one
how frequent is this problem mhm and she
said well actually when I'm in an area
that I know then I know where to walk I
know how to it's not African and how
intense is this problems like well you
know if I have to go over a curb or
something you know it's like it's a bit
Spain but it's not like you know yes
so that was like okay what if you could
start a problem that was addressing one
of the top three problems in your life
what would it be you know she said she
said affordable childcare I think you
know what a lot of people have that fail
that's a big problem and like I felt my
like douchebag investor that like go up
it's like yes you should do that like
that is a problem like even if you have
solved that problem you're gonna be
wildly successful like there are
gajillions people who have that problem
it's ridiculously intense it's like and
it was like interesting because in such
a weird way I feel like she had somehow
condensed all of the startup advice that
she'd been given and everything she read
to go to this like wrong place when I
just asked her what's the problem in
your life and she almost immediately got
to like a place that could create real
value yeah now like how should she solve
that problem okay yes that's another
question but damn like it's a personal
problem she has and she sure as hell
knows that if she makes a product is it
helping her yeah and at least if it's
helping her she knows it's like halfway
decent so like that I got to a really
exciting place by just digging into like
what sucks for you I think everyone can
do that exercise and I think that like
that exercise can be informed by your
work life or a personal life so many
startups I see or created because they
were doing something at work and they
were like this sucks why do I have to
keep on doing this I'm gonna make this
thing and then sell it to my job so that
no one has to do this over again right
so we can apply either way right and
this is a very easy way to get people to
pay you
yeah whereas doing things like strapping
a webcam to your head no it is not as
obvious of a problem pretty pretty
non-obvious so alright so once you find
a problem find some friends and
brainstorm potential solutions to the
problem
so here's the trick you don't need to
skip to a solution too early and your
thought process should be whatever
solution I come up with is probably
gonna be wrong so well my solution
really is is a first hypothesis and
basically it's like imagine I'm trying
to
I don't know like redo some famous
science experiment like I'm trying to
figure out the speed of gravity or
something right I first have to start
with a hypothesis then test and then
repeat repeat or be in flight to my
answer okay so I don't need to know the
answer up front like that's not the goal
if you have a big enough problem like
trust that like if you come up with
anything resembling an answer in a
reasonable period of time years yeah you
have a big business so instead of
thinking okay let me come with my idea
how to solve it I think the more
important thing is to start talking
other people about it because I think
that the number one thing you have to do
to create a company or one of the top
three is to have some co-founders and
it's really helpful to figure out who
the types of people who you can talk to
you about something and you riff well
you you iterate and share those ideas
there's some time people you brainstorm
with and like they say like I say Craig
wouldn't even cool if the sky is red and
Craig says no and that's the end of the
brain stem right and it's like well we
might have a best founder relationship
right as opposed to like well wouldn't
it be cool if the sky was red in crisis
you know we can make the sky red but
what happens if we like tint all the
windows in the house red so you can make
it look like this guy's red right it's
like oh right you know like we're moving
right so you want to start having those
conversations to people that you like
people if you're not technical people
who are technical people who you just
respect their intelligence and ideally
together you start coming up with an
idea and what's cool about that is that
if you co-op that idea together everyone
you've been talking to feel some
ownership of the idea yeah and that
helps kind of light that flame yeah yeah
it's dangerous to be married to a
solution yeah yes real problem all right
so at this point the most important
thing is to turn that spark into a fire
and work together to build an MVP boom
so biggest mistake that people make at
this point is to think that the things
they need to do is like now I feel like
some like weird
phantom MBA starts whispering in their
ear and it's like you need to
incorporate you need to raise the money
you need to did it it on it's like kick
that person out that person like that's
not it's not me to do
can you just build a simple view one of
the product can you put the simplest one
even if it's just an Excel spreadsheet
something power fighting so spreadsheet
give it a try
like the way to get that team even more
excited is to try something yeah and
like oftentimes I see people kind of get
lost in that legal or that fundraising
world and never even got to give their
thing a try you don't need you don't
need like bank accounts to give
something a try
you don't need an incorporation they
give something a try for the most part
there's some ideas you do but like for
the most part you don't and a way that
you can really get that team solidified
it's just to get some kind of MVP and
get like one customer two customers
mm-hmm
this is one the final test on like hey
can we work together well right and to
man it amps up the excitement a lot and
so that when you have to go through some
of the [ __ ] of incorporation and
stuff yeah or fundraising right the
excitement level is high yeah also third
it gives you leverage like if you
actually have something with a couple
customers and then like investors are
far more interested to like to talk to
you and if you just have an idea
especially people who are on the fence
about working with you yeah yeah I mean
yes all of these things that you're
saying these are all excuses you create
because it's easier than working on the
actual problem well yes for some people
but I also think it's for some people
it's what they think is the right path
it's like it's like I actually think
that some people some people are being I
don't say lazy but some people are being
I don't know not some people are kind of
being disingenuous in this process but I
think other people actually think oh no
the right thing to do is actually to
come up with an idea fundraise outsource
an MVP and then hire a team like I think
they like some people think that's the
right thing I do and it's like harder
that's a harder path okay you don't have
to do that well my failure mode is
different then alright so then you wrap
this a up with a couple things the two
failed
of operations well these are two of many
I suppose yes uh-huh
so one come up with an idea and then
pitch for investors
yes - I have an idea but can't write
code and none of my co-founders can
either yeah so we're in a time where
there are a lot of startups and there's
unfortunately you're people that you're
pitching if they're good they're getting
pitched by a lot of people so you need
to bring some real fire to that meeting
and a good deck is no longer good enough
I would argue that back in the day like
in the 90s it was so expensive to get
software made and hosted or online and
get users that like a good deck or
actually back then it was like a hundred
page business plan like that's all you
could get that's all you could do
without money no we're not there now and
so you're not bringing the fire if you
just bring in an idea
now some people can raise on just an
idea right and if you're one of those
lucky people it's great but like I don't
know like I rather be good than lucky in
terms of you know no technical
co-founder is like this is a constant
issue and I'm surprised by this like I
talked to a friend the other day who is
thinking about starting something it
doesn't have a technical co-founder yet
and even she was a little concerned
about getting one even though she's kind
of been in the texting of world and and
you know I had to encourage I had to
tell her no you can like you can do this
like it's not it's it's it's not not
only it is not gonna be that hard is
that like it's probably gonna be easier
than outsourcing the one thing remote
that I see a lot is that I see people
who can raise a little bit of money
mm-hmm go down the outsourcing route and
believe that they are progressing they
believe that the thing is moving forward
and what they don't realize is that for
the most part they're gonna need to
iterate anything that's created by those
outsourcers over and over and over and
over again and it gets pretty expensive
pretty fast
and so the Fairmont that I see so
constantly is outsourcing iterating with
that outsourcer do you run out of money
you know you haven't figured things out
yet and so you have to go to an investor
and say well I don't have anything I
need more money and like that's death
and like what's so sad about that death
is that like you've been kind of walking
that path the whole time but often you
don't realize it to the very end and
after you spent money and like sometimes
it's people's own money like they do
their sins and their savings to these
people and like I don't think the
outsourcing folks are bad or morally
morally wrong I just think that like
people should take the hustle that they
have and apply it to the number one
problem which is like it just turns out
that getting a technical co-founder
tends to be cheaper than paying an
outsourcer yeah yeah I mean I guess you
know to push back if you had someone
outsource something and then that got
you a couple customers then you found a
co-founder that's a great outcome well
it's interesting because I think that a
lot of people go into the outsourcing
route with that yeah
intention uh-huh but the thing that they
don't realize is that like they didn't
feel comfortable going and finding
technical co-founder now yeah and they
don't have any traction and they don't
have a product right most likely the
outcome is the outsourced will give them
a shitty product at shitty Viwa totally
yep they won't have any users then and
now they'll go after technical founder
with a shitty product and new users and
less money less weight and they want to
give the co-founder 10% yeah but they're
not actually in a better position yeah
so it's like like yes I think that
they're like one and I and I mention the
SA there are counter examples like there
are people who do go from contractor to
big company but it's just I would argue
it's a harder path and it's a path
that's much more likely to lose you a
lot of money your own money your money
you